foreign
[Music]
you're an interesting man
Scotland
you're an Avenger
[Music]
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time
like me
whip each other with that
how are you
I'm the man who can give you the one
thing you want
what's that
time
I can rewrite existence
and shatter timelines
you cannot trust him I don't care who
this guy is I just lost so much
[Music]
he can give us a second chance
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign I used to ask myself a lot of
questions Scott you're at ex-con
how are you an Avenger that doesn't make
sense but everywhere I go people tell me
the same thing thank you Spiderman
people still need help Dad that's why we
made this
like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah wait wait a minute you're sending
a signal down to the quantum Realm
turn it off now
[Music]
where
are we
listen to my own mind it's a secret
Universe beneath ours
what are you so afraid of
there's something I never told you do
this
it isn't what you think
[Music]
[Music]
I can get you home
and give you more time
if you help me
so
What's it gonna be
Ant-Man
[Music]
this guy
I need you to be the Ant-Man
you have a chance
the chance to earn that look in your
daughter's eyes
to become the hero
and she already thinks you are
Second Chances don't come around all
that much
[Music]
time works differently in the quantum
row what if we could enter at a certain
point in time
but then exit at another point in time
we can bring everyone back
all life happened because I messed up
not everybody gets a chance to save the
world
Avengers Assemble
Scotland
do a reality
everything you're holding on to
foreign
[Music]